then nancy pelosi trotted out she had a
couple vodka tonics and then she got out
there put her eyebrows on and then she
just couldn't get the crowd as fired up
as she wanted kitchen table items for
america's working families mr president
thank you for unifying and inspiring
a vision of a stronger
fairer
safer
future for all for our children your
extraordinary leadership has made this
glorious day possible
i that's an applause line
[Applause]
people people that's where you're
supposed to applaud you're not supposed
to be sleeping when i'm talking uh later
in her speech she referred to solar
panels his kitchen table issues because
that's always what people are talking
about over at the kitchen table and then
they brought out old joe and he just
screamed and rambled incoherently you
just have to remember who we are we are
the united states of america there is
nothing nothing nothing we've ever set
our mind do nothing that we've not been
not been able to accomplish
nothing beyond our capacity
and to just remember who we are
we stand together there's nothing beyond
our capacity
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just all of it the
anger which by the way is a symptom when
you have cognitive issues your emotional
regulation is not quite right and the
yelling and then picking his jacket up
off the floor like just the whole thing
it's just the optics are just so bad
foreign